meanwhile back at home the biden
administration is dealing with a
collapsing narrative on covet 19. peter
ducey was on his game today and his
questions about vaccines were dead on
take a look
i understand that the science says that
vaccines prevent death
but
on triple backs still got coveted your
triple backs still got cobid why is the
president still referring to this as a
pandemic
of the unvaccinated
well i think peter there's a significant
difference between and you just you just
experienced this and not to expose your
public health experience but i can speak
to mine as well i had been triple vaxxed
i had minor symptoms there is a huge
difference between that and being
unvaccinated will the president update
his language at some time to be more
reflective of the fact that people who
are triple vaccinated are catching and
spreading covenant i think people
president has said as have we a number
of times that there will be breakthrough
cases there will be people who get covid
saki also had a difficult time
explaining why the less favored
supreme court justice was spewing covert
misinformation from the bench and it was
bad take a look you guys have been very
aggressive countering covet
misinformation so what do you guys think
about covet misinformation coming from
the supreme court
and sonia sotomayor's false claim that
over a hundred thousand children are in
serious condition many on ventilators
well i'm not going to speak to supreme
court arguments or statements uh made in
those arguments
a hundred thousand kids 750 million
americans and last but not least peter
ducey also pressed gensake on why joe
biden was so unprepared for the winner
sir we didn't see it coming he said
why is it that you guys were so
unprepared
for the
need for testing after the holidays well
peter i'm happy to see you back and well
um i would second say that there has
been a massive surge in cases as you
know and we're a part of in dc and new
york and there's been an unprecedented
in other parts of the country as well
there's been an unprecedented demand for
tests the president talked about a
winter of severe illness and death at
the rate you guys are going these tests
are not going to be available until
spring so will you admit that these free
tests you guys promised are not going to
be ready until after the omicron surge i
think i gave an update earlier that
we'll have to start to have tests out
the door in the coming weeks very soon
now by the way tests are not available
america's supply chain crisis is still
ongoing picture after picture showing
empty shelves all across the country it
is clear to america tonight joe biden is
failing at a very high level thankfully
in less than a year a massive referendum
is now forthcoming joining us now fox
news white house correspondent our
friend peter ducey is with us so here's
a quote of joe biden if you get the
vaccine you're not going to get covert
uh the great doctor fauci himself if you
get the vaccine it'll prevent you from
getting covered
do they have an answer to that
they do and sean what we have seen over
the course of the last year plus is that
the vaccines are great they were
developed beginning under the trump
administration with operation warp speed
in record time they reduce debts they
reduce hospitalizations but they are not
at this point with this variant the
entire ballgame this is an
administration that from day one chose
to go all in on vaccines every single
covet event that they do they say the
number one thing you got to be doing is
get vaccinated that is great and that
worked for a long time and we even got
to a point for like two weeks here where
uh people who were vaccinated didn't
have to wear masks it was christmas all
i found is every american couldn't get a
test and joe biden said in the uh under
donald trump oh it's a travesty here
we're now in year three how do we run
out of tests how he never mentions
monoclonal antibodies except one time in
his vaccine mandate speech then he
mentions it and all of a sudden they
become in short supply why did that
happen where are the antivirals that
every is raving about where's operation
warp speed for all three of those things
so the two things about that number one
uh jen saki alluded to it there i tested
positive here at the white house last
monday morning for covid i wasn't
positive that i had it because i felt
okay i wanted to get another test near
where i live and i did what joe biden
said on tuesday just google test near me
uh not available they were all jammed up
if uh and the white house was telling me
to isolate so you're basically on ice
this website that they've been promising
that was going to be ready uh they were
talking about it weeks ago ready
sometime in january where you can just
put in your address and the
administration will send you a test
through the post office that's not
available right now either so they
missed their opportunity to
help people who were traveling over
christmas as at the same time that joe
biden's on tv warning about a winter of
severe illness and death so they've been
preparing for the transition in delaware
last year but here we are tests are
tough
well first of all we're glad you're okay
um great job today you're on your a-game
as always thank you i'm steve ducey i'm
brian killman and i'm ainsley earhart
and click here to subscribe to the fox
news youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis